I looked at Christmas trees, man.
I went to this place that just an incredible place that has all these Christmas
trees. I can't even remember where it was, but dude,
man Christmas is when did Christmas jumped the shark? Look, I love Christmas.
It's also so annoying when people talk about how
it's annoying, that that Christmas decorations go up too early.
It doesn't matter. It's one of those things that it's like you,
it's annoying as it's as annoying as what you're annoying annoyed about
what you're doing. You know, it's like, it's,
it's like just Christmas is coming it's and calming.
Christmas is coming and it's fine. It's fine. Christmas is coming,
you know, but if you want to be, you know,
not involved in it, then don't be involved in it when people are like in LA,
like, Oh, I hate you. You go to the Grove and it's, first of all,
don't go to the Grove. Okay. If you go to the Grove,
you're going to have the most Gropius experience of all time.
And the most Gropius experience of all time is Christmas at the Grove in LA,
you go to the Grove and it's like, during Christmas time you have like a,
it's like an outdoor mall or whatever. LA has some outdoor malls.
Cause it never rains. Why would you live anywhere else? And so,
and so they ha they decorated in like August,
starting for Christmas because they want to make bags and they want to remain
downloads. And I get it, dude, they wanna remain dollars. But um,
people complain about it. It it's the most annoying thing.
It's not that annoying when you go to the Grove and there's Garland around who
cares?
You're just don't look at it or don't go to top shop, you know,
where you can get a shoot for $25 a three-piece suit for $25 in that rips on the
red carpet.
Oh really? Hey Tom. You're at top shop. Hey, how much is this three-piece suit?
17 bucks. Really? Yeah. Can I try it on? No, it'll rip. All right. I'll take it.
You know, it's like H and M when you're like, Whoa,
this jacket is pretty gnarly, dude. I'm going to get this cool. Ring it up,
dude. Accept it. Boom. Sign here. Great sign. Cool. Yeah.
Let me just say head on out of the shop and get, get to my car. Okay. Bye guys.
[inaudible] what's H and M Stanford. Holy moly.
It's going to rip soon. Yeah, dude.
It, this is another podcast. We will cut that part out. Oh, we don't do it.
Which seasons get Holy moly. H and M Holly. Molly.
Uh, yeah, so I saw a Christmas tree with the flamingos all over it by
Hey, big tall flamingos all over the Christmas tree. You know,
don't put things as big as the Christmas tree on the Christmas tree,
you know, Christmas tree with the big,
some people will put big presence in the Christmas tree.
Like to hang them up on there. It looks bad.
Now I'm going to be honest with you. It looks bad also,
dude. Christmas is coming. Okay. And,
and if you're annoyed that Christmas is coming,
we'll be annoyed at the podcast because this podcast is saying Christmas is
coming and it's already, it's only November. Okay. But
it's never a Flamingo Christmas. Okay. Sometimes I see things online.
I think online, it's a very Merry Flamingo Christmas. Guess what?
It's not ever a Flamingo Christmas,
but dude, I saw ones with like, I mean there's somewhere with Christmas,
with the sharks on it and probably,
but there's so much decorations on Christmas trees in these Christmas tree
places. And I get it is because this is their life and this is their,
they can start getting rid of this, these Christmas.
It's like those Halloween shops that are just only,
they only really function in October. And it's like, how?
You're not going out of business. These Christmas places,
they're ready to get. They're ready to get going in August. You know?
So you, so they decorate every last part. It's like my mom on meth.
My mom, if you go to her house,
every little place has got chotchkies all over it. Do I hate it? Yes.
Is she my mom? Yes. Do I love her still? Yes, but dude,
chotchkies everywhere man. And uh, this Christmas place, they got Bose,
they got tinsel. They've got flamingos. They've got, uh,
and it's just so much to it.
Anyway,
what I like is red and green.
And I like the Christmas trees that are,
the ornaments are hung up different ornaments. So it looks like a family did it.
I don't like this store-bought. Why would you take that feeling at a Christmas?
Is your house, your house or is it Bloomingdale's? You know,
if you have kids make the kids hang up the school bus ornaments or whatever,
you know, that's it.
Um, my, my grandpa would, would, would, would,
would have his kid, his kids do the trees and my, which was my dad.
Obviously, if you know anything about lineage and my, and he would be like,
he would sit in his chair and it would be like,
put it that go right there. That's where that one goes.
And my dad would be like here and from the chair,
my grandpa Ben will be like, no, right, dad,
my dad would be like one here. Now there's a spot right there. Right here.
Right. There's where I'm pointing. Not there, there.
And he'd be like 20 feet out.
That's what I'm going to do to my kid. Dude. Put it there. Where there,
where there? Right here that I say they're there and he's going to be three.
I don't know what to do. Where to put, this is too high to put up there.
I can't get up there.
Okay.
Use a step stool. Have your mother hold you up. They're there. Hey you,
there, you hold him there. Where here dad hold him here.
Yeah. Now put it there. Son. Put it there. Where they're here.
Okay.
Everyone just screaming there at my whole family. Another daughter.
We're not put this one there. Put it, give it to him. Pulled him.
Have your mother home him. hold on there.
Hang up the star on this one. Is that the top there?
Um, dude, I can't wait to have kids and make them crazy as, dude.
Um, yeah. So, and also, Hey, I got some news for you, man.
I know that. crazy about the in the holiday season. We always keep hearing the,
Hey, it's not a Christmas tree. It's a holiday tree. I don't give a what it is,
dude. Call it a holiday tree. What the do I care? Who cares?
Call it a Subaru. What's it matter, dude.
It's green and you're hang school. Bus ornaments on it.
You put tensile all over it. Who cares? There was this one guy who tweeted.
This is not a holiday tree. It's a Christmas tree. Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right. Cool. Good. Have a have, have, have dinner. What do I give a?
You call it. You call it when someone gets mad. Hey,
this is a Christmas tree. Oh, okay. You mean the holiday tree?
Imagine being like, no, no, no. I mean Christmas tree. Imagine getting that mad.
If I say that's a Christmas tree, you mean holiday tree. I go like this. Yeah.
Right. Dad who gives a?
The people who are outraged, it should stop with the people who are outraged.
You don't get more outraged. Who gives a, man, that being said,
sometimes your boy gets outraged. But yeah, man,
that's so weird. When somebody gets mad, this isn't a, um,
a holiday candle. This is a,
what do they call the Hanukkah things menorah.
So now is it weird that menorah,
if you shorten the word it's manure and that means. Yes.
Have I always thought that? Yes. What came first?
Menorah or manure does? No,
but I'm pretty sure her she's were for centuries and centuries.
Why wouldn't, why didn't you? Why weren't Jews like, Oh boy,
maybe we should change it. Let's call it a menorah.
Well, okay. But that sounds like horse.
What the hell does it matter? Ho, CAS light him up.
Ah.
What should we call it? Poopy candles. A menorah.
Well,
can't call the poopy poopy candles or not because it's got poopy in it.
Menorah. It is. Hi.
Dude. Whatever you can't get mad at me. I'm Jewish.
I don't dude,
Man, people are so, I don't want to always talk about how people are outraged,
but everybody's outrageous and get their holiday trees or holiday candles.